[Music]
this is one of the fastest motions in
nature
faster than the blink of an eye
faster than your naked eye can even see
these Technicolor murder machines are
called mantis shrimp and they might just
be the coolest animal in the entire
ocean and I don't say that lightly and
if the speed of their clubs of up to 31
meters per second isn't impressive
enough the acceleration of those clubs
Rivals the acceleration of a bullet
being fired from a gun for a human to
break the same shells that a mantis
shrimp breaks we would need a big hammer
and a strong swing a manta shrimp can
achieve the same thing with an appendage
smaller than a small child's pinky
finger these guys help make up an entire
category of the natural world that's
only been recently described the ultra
fast forget about the fastest human or
even something like a cheetah those
don't even register on the ultra fast
scale instead it's populated by
extraordinarily fast creatures such as
trap jaw ants launching fungal spores
ballistic termite jaws and stinging
jellyfish
Fishers working around shallow reefs
have attested to the damage a mantis
shrimp can do to their bare hands and
feet and Aquarium owners have to be
especially careful not to annoy their
powerful Little Friends these guys can
sometimes punch through extremely thick
glass and will decimate any other
animals living alongside them in the
tank these Wiley Fighters are among the
most ferocious carnivores in the ocean
and yet curiously the fastest species
among them prey almost exclusively on
the slowest creatures like snails and
oysters and the slower species go for
the fastest prey snatching Creatures two
or three times their size from crabs to
octopuses and not only are mantis shrimp
extremely fast at punching and stabbing
their eyes are the most complex in the
entire Animal Kingdom whereas humans
have three types of photoreceptor cells
in our eyes mantis shrimp have between
12 and 16 types of photoreceptors they
see ultraviolet light and polarized
light and their eyes are so Advanced
that their retina processes visual
information before it even gets to their
brain scientists are beginning to
explore whether mantis shrimp eyes could
even see cancer before it starts to
spread what is it about these little
creatures that makes them so fast so
ferocious and so extreme and how do
these obscure Crustaceans harness the
laws of physics in ways we have never
been able to replicate
mantis shrimp are small colorful and
aggressive Crustaceans that live in
tropical and subtropical Waters but for
all that they're usually only about 10
centimeters or 4 inches long the very
largest might get to be 40 centimeters
or 15 inches only a little bigger than a
foot long sub the order stomatopoda to
which all mantis shrimp belong separated
from other Crustaceans around 400
million years ago then over the next 200
million years the shrimp-like ancestor
of modern mantis shrimps had some of
their mouth Parts morph into raptorial
claws giving them the predatory
appearance of praying mantises from
which they took their name these types
of mantis shrimp came to be classified
as spearers and their deadly claws shape
everything from the way they hunt to how
they live take the world's largest
mantis shrimp for example the zebra
mantis shrimp it can grow up to 40
centimeters in size and hunts as an
ambush Predator living in Sandy Burrows
on the shallow sea floor only its eyes
poking out as it waits for its prey it's
impossible for fish to see the zebra
mantis shrimp hidden in the sand and by
the time it strikes it's too late for
escape the spears shoot out at a speed
of 2.3 meters per second impaling the
fish on 10 sharp spines that jut out
from its claws in one experiment
researchers found that most zebra mantis
shrimp strikes were successful in
capturing fish but if you've ever tried
to trap a fly with your hand you might
be able to imagine how hard it is to
snap up prey and hold on to it how do
they do it
first there is the raptorial claw itself
it's designed to be strong but also
flexible because it needs to slice
through soft flesh and then hold on to
it while the fish tries to get away to
achieve all this the spear has several
spikes which are slightly hooked Hollow
beams made of several layers on the
outside is a thin hard and mineralized
epicutical decorated by serrations and
grooves to lock onto its prey on the
inside is a less mineralized region with
fibrous layers of chitin protein to
allow for flexibility unlike something
like a bee stinger or a mosquito
proboscis both of which are straight to
maximize how deep they can penetrate the
mantis shrimp spearing Claw is curved
this helps it keep a hold onto its prey
to understand more about the Ecology of
mantis shrimp we talked to Dr Maya
DeVries who spent years studying mantis
shrimp both in the lab and in the field
when we capture them in the fields we do
take advantage of their prey mechanism
will put squid or fish on a lure and
then we will lure them out of their
Burrows that way and then we we have
like a little noose that's around the
burrow so it comes out and then we're
able to kind of cook it the next element
of the spears strike is how it achieves
such high speeds first flexor and
extensor muscles in the Maris are
engaged the extensor muscles compress
the claw while the flexor muscles
trigger a latch to lock into place when
the flexor muscle relaxes and the latch
slips open the claw strikes out at
incredibly high speeds while at the same
time the mantis shrimp lunges out of its
burrow with a fish now trapped in its
claws it drags its meal back into the
sand to feast and we couldn't resist
asking Dr DeVries the burning question
on our minds
um have you ever been speared thankfully
never a sphere never conspired that
sounds scary because these mantis shrimp
live in the sand it's pretty easy to
move from one place to another that
means they tend not to be very
aggressive when it comes to defending
their homes it just isn't worth the risk
of injury
but that is absolutely not the case when
it comes to the other type of mantis
shrimp the ones with Incredible smashing
claws
somewhere along the way of their
evolutionary path a small subset of
mantis shrimp changed from being Spears
to Smashers instead of growing
terrifying spines from their raptorial
claws these shrimp developed clubs that
look much less formidable but looks can
be deceiving because these clubs achieve
some of the fastest speeds in nature
whereas the zebra mantis shrimp can
extend its spear at a speed of 2.3
meters per second Smashers like the
purple spot mantis shrimp extend their
clubs at a speed of 31 meters per second
with an acceleration of well over 100
000 meters per second squared this is an
acceleration greater than a 22 caliber
bullet fired from a pistol their clubs
can produce around 1500 Newtons or 340
pounds of force impact forces thousands
of times greater than their body weight
but when scientists were first studying
the impact forces of these punches
something absolutely weird was showing
up in the force graph there was one
Spike showing for the punch as you'd
expect but another second Spike would
happen soon after the punch and when
reviewing the footage of this moment the
scientists saw something else weird a
bubble forming and a flash of light
they realized that the mantis shrimp
Club was bouncing back after hitting the
shell so fast that it creates a small
area of extremely low pressure and when
pressure drops this low in water the
water instantly vaporizes AKA it boils
this creates a vapor bubble called a
cavitation bubble but this bubble
doesn't last long the pressure from the
water all around the bubble forces it to
collapse and when this happens energy is
released in the form of sound heat and
light this energy is so strong that it
heats up to temperatures that rival the
surface of the Sun stuns the Mantis
shrimp's prey for a second time and
creates that second Peak on the graph
to understand this strange phenomenon we
talked to the scientist who first
discovered it Dr Sheila Paddock so when
we saw the cavitation bubbles for the
first time it really was like actually
thrilling and we knew that that that was
probably the first time anybody had seen
it because the technology just hadn't
even been there we were using the newest
latest greatest cameras do you think
do the produce that rotation bubble or
do you think the cavitation bubble is
like a nice side effect for them
you know my careful scientist answer
would be I don't know
um just as a as an observer I would say
that they did evolve to cavitate because
it's so robust like it's just no matter
what they hit a cavities they don't
cavitate at the wrong time they cavitate
at the right time some of the data we
have show that you'll have like Four
Peaks in a row that are evenly spaced so
to me that looks to me like something
that has actually evolved whereas some
of the other animals that we've studied
that cavitate including this really
hilarious tiny shrimp that we published
about also has an incredibly fast human
being
appendage that shoots a water jet but it
only cavitates if the water jet happens
to hit something somewhere along its
path and that starts to look a bit more
like an accident as opposed to this sort
of incredibly robust Phenomenon with the
with the Mantis room
given how different the attack is for
Smasher shrimp than their Spirit
relatives their prey is also very
different they tend to eat things with
hardened exoskeletons like oysters and
snails with these prey extreme force is
necessary for cracking them open and the
cavitation bubbles are definitely
helpful but this all seems like a
counter-intuitive evolutionary result
that the fastest animals prey on the
slowest but it's likely not a
coincidence
a hint as to why this Paradox might
exist can be seen while watching a
clubbing mantis shrimp prepare to break
a shell first it touches Wiggles and
positions the shell exactly where it
wants it it Taps the Shell with its
antenna seems to wait a moment and then
it strikes
the key to it all is in the moment it
seems to be waiting this is the moment
that enables the Smashing mantis shrimp
to be so fast the moment this mantis
shrimp needs to take to be able to
strike and the reason it prefers prey
that won't really move while It prepares
to do so the shrimp is winding up Spring
loading its claw to an extraordinary
degree
the spring in question is shaped like a
saddle which is made up of chitin and
sits on top of the claw in the moment
just before the strike the shrimp's
muscles compress it and holds it back
with a latching mechanism then when it's
time to strike this potential energy is
released and the club swings forwards
this saddle spring mechanism allows the
club to be released at an enormous
velocity a much higher velocity than any
muscle would be capable of producing by
itself the spearing mantis shrimp also
has a saddle like this but it's much
less effective
the easiest way to understand it is by
comparing your performance throwing an
arrow versus launching one with a bow
just throwing the arrow using your arm
muscles will probably not make it go
very far nor very fast but use those
same arm muscles to flex a bow and then
release the arrow with your fingers
suddenly the arrow goes much farther and
much faster and yet the energy input is
the same whether or not a bow is used
the only difference is the time over
which the energy is released so in other
words it's a small amount of energy but
the intensity of the release is
extremely high
so a lot of people are like oh you know
they're very powerful animals and they
use so much energy but actually they
just really don't they use very little
energy and they release it over short
periods of time which is very explosive
the design of their raptorial Claw is
also quite different than the spirit of
shrimp because the club has to withstand
such immense forces repeatedly the
exterior of the club is covered by a
crack resistant coating a little like
the tape boxers use for binding their
hands underneath that coating are two
regions with fibers aligned in different
directions one area of fibers dissipates
cracks while the other stops the club
from expanding on impact
all of this means that the shrimp can
batter away on a clam shell or even a
glass aquarium wall without damaging its
claw and we know that the Manta shrimp
have a very good sense of the
three-dimensional structure and
mechanics of the shells that they're
hitting and that in fact they will hit
the shells at the most efficient
structural locations to break them so
you give them a high spired shell or
globular shell and they'll hit them
differently and we've seen from our
physical models of manta shrimp that
that sequence that they're using is
actually the most efficient to break
those geometries because Smasher mantis
shrimp hunt prey that live on rocks and
coral they also live in very different
habitats and it turns out their clubs
come in handy for more than just hunting
by having that superpower appendage to
break open snail shells that means that
that food is available to them but it
also means that they can use it for a
bunch of other things like knocking out
a crab oh and I should say some species
of Smashing mantis shrub
um build Burrows with their hammers that
they create by like break you know
inside the coral they'll bang out all
the little sections and they'll be like
a perfect little house inside the coral
which of course is a very nice protected
home
they prefer hard substrates for their
Burrows which means real estate is at
much more of a premium the borough needs
to be big enough for them to fit but
small enough that they can block the
entrance with their tail and that means
these mantis shrimp regularly get into
fights over Burrows and these fights can
get very aggressive one group of
researchers found that sparring strikes
actually pack more energy into them than
Strikes used for predation so we had to
ask Dr Paddock the same question is
there ever any occupational hazard
handling these guys are your fingers
ever in danger yeah no I mean you do
have to be careful the bigger problem is
that they have a spike at the end of
their appendage and if that goes in your
skin it's really unpleasant but you know
I mean if you have a cat you know like
with claws you know you just gotta learn
how to work with the cat right it's the
same idea so it's pretty rare that
anybody has a problem there are like
kind of crazy story stories out there
about people who like lost a finger
because of a manta shrimp but usually
it's because
you know they they were like diving and
they stuck their hand down the hole and
then the thing hit them and then they
didn't move and so then the animal
speared them and then they get all the
bacteria in their finger like like these
are like this honestly never happened to
us and it never will like these are just
really weird stories that end up on the
Internet
um but for the most part they don't even
want to spear you even the spears don't
want to spear you because if they get
their appendage stuck in your skin
they're gonna lose the appendage so more
typically they just hit you with the
hammer or with the bass like with the
spearers and that doesn't hurt that much
I've been hit bajillion times including
in the field because at the end of the
day it's dangerous to be a mantis shrimp
luckily mantis shrimp have an incredibly
hard armor over their body and
especially their telsin or tail and this
armor has raised protuberances that
protect them from fracturing even when
they take such heavy blows so it's clear
that the different types of raptorial
claws play a huge role in determining
everything about the mantis shrimp's
lives but it's not only their claws but
dictate much of their behavior it's also
their eyes
mantis shrimp are often said to have the
most complex eyes of any creature in the
animal kingdom and they might be the
part of their body that makes them look
the most alien and these eyes help them
to be such effective Predators they do
have this amazing predatory Vision
because they have two eyes that move
independently and each eye has
trinocular Vision you know we binocular
vision they have trinocular Vision I
honestly can't even conceptualize what
that looks like
but so together they have hex nocular
Vision so they are able to take in an
incredible amount of information and
that very likely improves the success of
their ability to Target things the rest
of their body
having trinocular Vision in each eye
gives them depth perception from just
one eyeball a useful adaptation if you
regularly get into fights with rivals or
other predators and end up losing an eye
the three regions of the eye have
pseudo-pupils that can scan different
parts of the environment but the part
that most interests researchers is the
mid-band it has six rows of thousands of
omitidia or photoreceptor cells which
are used to detect specific wavelengths
of light including ultraviolet light
altogether they have 12 to 16 kinds of
photoreceptors in their eyes humans by
comparison have just three dogs have
only two and birds have four allowing
them to perceive ultraviolet light which
is not part of the visible spectrum for
humans
and yet scientists have found mantis
shrimp aren't actually all that good at
discriminating between colors in one
experiment they trained 10 mantis shrimp
to recognize 10 different color
wavelengths respectively ranging from
400 to 650 nanometers they did this by
showing the mantis shrimp two colors and
giving them a frozen prawn when they
picked the right wavelength after the
mantis shrimp were adequately trained
the scientists presented them with more
colors they found that the shrimp could
detect between the chosen wavelength and
another color as long as that color was
50 to 100 nanometers up or down the
Spectrum but if the difference between
wavelengths was 12 to 25 nanometers they
couldn't tell them apart and yet humans
with our three measly photoreceptor
types can differentiate millions of
colors and we have little trouble seeing
between wavelengths that are only five
nanometers apart although they can see
this incredibly wide spectrum of light
and wavelengths they don't see color
obviously the way we do they can't
actually distinguish between different
tones of colors for example like blue
dark blue a yellow that kind of thing so
we might actually see a widering color
in in that way the researchers
hypothesized that maybe each
photoreceptor in a mantis shrimp picks
up a specific color and identifies it in
a way that's less discriminating than
the human eye but also doesn't require
so much brain power that way they can
quickly determine if something is
predator or prey or they're processing A
Vision Works more like our processing of
hearing which is a a little bit more
step wise and on and off whereas our
vision is continuous
um we've seen like continuous Spectra
these photoreceptors might also help
them detect polarized light which is a
very special skill among animals
to understand this we first have to
understand how light moves normally the
wavelengths of light vibrate in every
direction along vertical and horizontal
axes it's random and chaotic and it's
most of what we see
polarized light is when the wavelengths
vibrate in only a certain direction say
on the vertical plane or horizontal
plane polarization can happen through
reflection or refraction which happens
in the water or by applying a filter
like polarized sunglasses it's not
something humans can see but other
creatures like octopus squid crabs and
cuttlefish can see some types of
polarized light
but Manta shrimp can see six types of
polarization horizontal vertical two
diagonals and two types of circular
polarization when the light waves spiral
clockwise or counterclockwise they're
the only animals we know of who can see
circularly polarized light
researchers think this not only helps
them scan their surroundings for prey
but also for communication they found
that certain species of mantis shrimp
have body parts that display circular
polarization patterns which could be
used in fighting or mating and mantis
shrimp are able to process much of this
visual stimuli before it even reaches
the part of their brain that acts as a
visual cortex thanks to something called
a reniform body this kidney-shaped
structure is located in the eye stalks
of the mantis shrimp and connects
directly to their brain it seems that it
helps them quickly process color and
other visual information and send that
onto the brain so that all the
information can be managed as quickly as
possible
the incredible adaptations of the mantis
shrimp haven't just astonished
zoologists and anatomists they've also
spurred us towards new Innovations in a
variety of fields materials scientists
in particular are interested in mantis
shrimp claws to help in developing
strong yet flexible compounds others
built a 1.5 gram sized robot that
mimicked a smash or mantis shrimp and it
was able to punch faster than any
similar device of its size though still
not as fast as the mantis shrimp itself
researchers who work in Optics have
modeled different types of cameras off
mantis shrimp eyes from polarized
cameras that can be used underwater to
cameras that might help in the detection
of cancerous cells before they spread
out into the body and the research is
still ongoing with plenty of more
discoveries to be made in just the past
few years researchers discovered that
mantis shrimp have twice as many light
detecting proteins in their eyes as we
expected we don't understand yet why
this is the case but it offers another
tantalizing direction to explore
the ocean is still full of incredible
diversity and discoveries waiting to be
made nowhere is this more true than the
deep sea a place that haunts our
imagination with creatures that
sometimes look too bizarre to even be
real
these deep sea creatures are the focus
of our next video where we will explore
why it is that creatures seem to get
weirder and weirder the deeper in the
ocean you go to watch this video right
now two weeks early head over to nebula
thanks to a feature we're calling nebula
first every real science video is posted
on nebula two weeks before it ever
reaches YouTube nebula is the streaming
platform made by me and several other
educational YouTube content creators
it's a place where we can take more
risks upload videos early and post
original content that doesn't
necessarily fit on YouTube there are so
many original series like becoming human
our series on the incredible story of
human evolution Joe's Scott's Mysteries
of the human body which takes you
through some of the most baffling
diseases and epidemics from history or
Wendover Productions extremities which
shows you why and how people live in
Earth's most isolated and extreme
settlements nebula has even produced a
feature-length film called night of the
coconut and a genre bending
award-winning play called the prince
which you can watch in its entirety on
nebula and now if you sign up with the
link below subscribers also get access
to nebula classes you can watch dozens
of in-depth classes of creators teaching
you how to create nebula is a gold mine
for fun and educational content all with
no ads so if you sign up using the link
below you can support this channel
directly and get both nebula and nebula
classes for 40 off the annual plan for
just thirty dollars for the entire year
foreign